after 177 episodes The Walking Dead has
finally come to a conclusion well sort
of are zombies evolving when was shown
ever end up finding Rick fans definitely
have questions about plenty of loose
ends and we're here to explore the most
pressing of them
and premiered on Halloween of 2010 we
were introduced to Rick Grimes who woke
up from a coma in the middle of a zombie
apocalypse the fast-paced horror of that
episode gave way to years of
post-apocalyptic social drama spending
practically no time exploring what
happened to courtsy outbreak there have
been plenty of hints as to what
initially caused the outbreak for
instance an episode of tales of the
Walking Dead set in the future notes
that scientists eventually learned that
the virus was created in a French
laboratory likewise we've seen something
of the catastrophic early days of the
infestation through the underrated
spin-off The Walking Dead World Beyond
as several children experienced some of
their earliest memories of losing their
parents to the sudden influx of Undead
yet there are still plenty of questions
around what exactly caused the outbreak
and it's hard to say if the franchise is
ever going to address them in many ways
the beauty of The Walking Dead is that
we don't actually need to know what
happened but we can't help be curious
Riggs farewell to The Walking Dead
series in the ninth season is epic
despite hallucinating and being near
death he manages to divert a horde of
Undead away from his friends and family
when an explosion takes out a mass of
the Walkers it seems certain that
Wreckers met his demise as he is nowhere
to be found afterward enter Jadis to be
meet in the seventh season as the leader
of the Scavengers her time with the
group shows her to be an enigmatic and
puzzling character and she ultimately
leaves to join the militaristic CRM when
we see her again in The Walking Dead
World Beyond she makes veiled references
that could easily prove she knows more
about Rick's whereabouts than anyone and
I created a ticket to get into the Civic
Republic I gave the CRM something very
valuable Jadis saves Rick with the help
of a helicopter and then the series
jumps six years into the future when
Michonne writes diary entries to her
presumably late husband however in the
10th season Michonne finds Rick's boots
and an old iPhone with her And Judith's
faces carved onto its surface and she
realizes that Rick is very likely still
alive leading her to head off to find
him in the finale it seems more likely
than ever that we're eventually going to
figure out what Rick has been up to but
currently it's still a mystery since
Rick has always been the face of the
series it goes without saying that his
fate is possibly the most pressing
question fans have
The Walking Dead is well known for
introducing epic big bads from the
governor to Negan to Alpha and the
whisperers for the 11th season the major
enemy is a seemingly non-violent Pamela
Milton who disappears countless
Commonwealth citizens approved
problematic to her aiding her is a
hateful and spoiled son Sebastian as
well as Lance Hornsby a politician who
constantly likes to get people on his
side only to revoke his support in
crucial moments to colonize the outlying
communities in some sort of manifest
destiny plan that we may never see the
full extent of Sebastian and Lance both
meet satisfying deaths and Pamela gets
captured after her evil actions are made
known to the citizens of the
Commonwealth but maybe that's not the
last we'll see of Pamela
though there are plenty of surprises
with the undead in the early seasons of
the show over time they become more of a
static background threat that could
occasionally Leap Forward and take loved
ones if you aren't constantly alert
living humans Remain the most
unpredictable threat in the
post-apocalypse while the undead stink
to traveling in herds and feeding this
final season changes that and the danger
of the grow exponentially through
several episodes different characters
notice odd developments with the zombies
surprised to find them in places that
they shouldn't have been able to go
casually dropping hints to viewers that
the undead might be evolving into a
greater threat than ever before when a
group takes refuge in an abandoned
Township they see the extent of this as
a walker not only scales a wall but
opens a door simply by using the handle
previously zombies could only burst
through barriers but using deductive
skills was not a thing they could pull
off during the attack on the
Commonwealth we see more of them coming
over fences and walls demonstrating
again that the undead are getting
smarter
from the beginning of The Walking Dead
up to his death in the eighth season
Carl Grimes played a major role as his
father Rick's right-hand man when Rick
cheated on the edge and nearly giving in
to his Dark Side Cole was able to call
him back pointing out that his own
belief system to prevent him from
Crossing those lines in that way the
Next Generation has always played a huge
role in the morality of the franchise
with Rick Michonne and Carl all gone
Judith becomes a major character over
the last few seasons showing the same
determination and heroism as her parents
Judith is able to defend the other
children but also takes part in major
events while inspiring the adults around
her to keep their eyes on the prize
during conflicts what we're doing could
help everyone
not just us but maybe everybody
everywhere though we almost lose her in
the finale due to a gunshot wound Judith
survives leading us to wonder where she
and the other children will go from here
we have no idea where Rick has been over
the last several years though the hints
dropped in the finale suggests he's
probably in need of some help we see him
decked out in a CRM jacket stuck at a
riverbank dismayed by the number of
Undead stuck in the mud and snapping at
his feet he throws his backpack on a
boat to keep it from being confiscated
leaving a trail from a shown to find as
a voice through a loudspeaker warns him
[Music]
if there is one thing we have seen time
and again in this series it's Michonne
putting off superhuman Feats of Bravery
as Rick surrenders to his captors images
are intercut with Michonne who has never
stopped searching for him alone and
surrounded by The Horde she continues on
hacking away at the undead with her
trusty blade and riding an armored horse
into battle in search of her love reckon
Michelle will no doubt see a reunion
between the two even if only through
memories and flashbacks but it's not
guaranteed that Michonne and Rick will
make it to safety with Michonne fans
across the globe holding their breasts
we're hoping to get some answers in 2023
this season spends a lot of time delving
into the animosity between long time fan
favorite Maggie Green and the villain
turned anti-hero Negan who murdered her
husband Glenn during his time as a
ruthless leader of the saviors
understandably Maggie is still upset
about this despite negan's presence as a
helpful member of the Alexandria
Community killing you
it's on my mind now married and soon to
be a father Negan is wrapped with guilt
over what he's done and attempts to
sacrifice himself to a firing squad to
save the others but sir Negan shark he
gets rescued by Ezekiel and other
members of the community stepping up
around him and Annie after that he
apologizes to Maggie for the first time
telling her that it took all of the
horrors they've been through for him to
fully understand what he had taken from
her I am so sorry
thank you
for what I took from you
what I took from your son though she
tells him she can't forgive him she
admits that she's ready to move forward
which will open the door for that
pending spin-off dead City however we
still don't know how they end up in New
York
after Rick and Michonne leave the series
Daryl makes a seamless transition into a
central role where he spends more time
with the community helps to raise Judith
and even works for Mercer as one of the
Commonwealth soldiers his dedication to
the community has been clear since the
early days and he's always been a true
friend to both Rick and Michonne during
their time as leaders more so than
almost anyone else he and Carol have
remained vital characters surprising us
countless times by jumping in and saving
the day the finale sees Daryl spending
most of his time trying to keep Judith
alive as The Horde overruns the streets
of the Commonwealth in her Delirious
State upon waking up Judith admits to
Daryl that Michonne is on a quest to
find Rick surprised to hear that his
friends are still alive he doesn't make
any immediate moves until he cut to the
one year later segment that ends the
series Daryl says a touching goodbye to
Carol while preparing to head off on his
own Journey where is he going we're not
sure birds were guessing that reckon was
shown her at the end of that path
the ending of The Walking Dead was
pretty great overall but the series
couldn't fully manage to Grant adequate
screen time to its countless amazing
characters though args for many
characters wrapped up or at least put
them on the path to their next adventure
plenty of others struggle to find a
resolution the Commonwealth is now the
home of many recurring characters from
sisters Connie and Kelly to King Ezekiel
himself and these old people were dying
to see more of since Magnus group first
appeared in the ninth season they've
counterbalanced a loss of major cast
members by repeatedly proving their
survival skills are unmatched Eugene and
Max fought hard for their relative sense
of Peace but are we ever going to see
what Eugene is like as a dad and there's
a video game worth a pre-order over the
years The Walking Dead has been
surprisingly Adept at tying up its loose
ends and viewers seldom lose sight of a
major character or plot thread without
some sort of explanation however the
people behind the show are only human so
there are still a handful of questions
left over from the earlier Seasons that
we've never quite resolved for instance
way back in the fourth season Grady
Memorial Hospital was shown to be
overrun by villainous monsters
masquerading as Healthcare officials but
after Beth Green's death we never hear
about it again even though Daryl killed
the head of the organization we've spent
years wondering what happened to
everyone else another question that has
fans scratching their heads is what does
a Civic Republic been up to we're pretty
sure they have to be aware of major
townships at the Commonwealth we've seen
their ends justify the means approach up
close and personal Through The Walking
Dead World Beyond but their status as
ruthless Protectors of humanity has
always been a bit vague we're dying to
hear more
with Hilltop destroyed in both
Alexandria and Oceanside having been
invaded by Commonwealth soldiers is
harder than ever to understand what's
going on in the outlying communities and
their Fates are even more jeopardized
now that so many of their best and
brightest members are all heading off in
different directions the benevolent King
Ezekiel is unlikely to ever turn his
back on the other communities
particularly the ones he once found are
home in Aaron was uniquely committed to
Alexandria which means he very well
might return to it as a leader and Usher
in a new era the full status of
Oceanside and whether it will make a
comeback is unknown but we're looking
forward to finding out soon
[Music]